j les gens qui sont ils victimes ou
coupables alors on a donc yoann qu'on a
entendu il ya un instant donc gilet
jaune mais anti blocage c'est très bien
exprimer merci d'être avec nous en tout
cas on à côté pierre louis étudiant en
management du sport anti gilet jaune
participant actif aux nouvelles hashtag
balances ton gilet jaune
on a en face yohan delattre merci d'être
là yoann avait rien à discuter un peu
aussi vous êtes chimiste vous êtes
porte-parole des gilet jaune à calais et
on a alors il prend un risque vraiment
c'est vrai noam doit manoir policiers
délégué vigie police projet les jaunes
vous dépendez du ministère de
l'intérieur et pourtant vous soutenez
les filets jaunes je ne suis pas
favorable à aux étiquettes pour contre
et c'est pour moi la vie est un petit
peu plus compliqué que cette dichotomie
qu'on nous impose ses les choses sont un
peu plus cet ancien des renseignements
généraux vous dépendez du ministère de
l'intérieur
oui est ce que vous prenez un risque en
venant dire ce soir en direct sur notre
plateau que vous êtes donc vous êtes
soutenez les gilet jaune ce que c'est la
position du syndicat que je représente
ici ce soir vigie police que nous sommes
deux syndicats à avoir tenu des
positions qu'on pourrait qualifier de
favorable à ce mouvement de contestation
il ya le syndicat sgp unité qui a appelé
le 17 novembre dernier à une journée
sans pv donc sans verbaliser assez ça
c'est ce qu'on avait vu et nous sur le
principe effectivement on défend les
revendications du peuple français parce
que notre premier serment en tant que
policier c'est la défense des
institutions républicaines et le service
au peuple français et je ne fais pas
contrairement à certains invités puisque
j'ai écouté la première partie de
l'émission
la distinction aussi net est aussi
claire entre les gilet jaune et peuple
français pour moi messieurs dames vous
êtes le peuple français
effectivement nous sommes en démocratie
mais nous sommes avant tout une
institution à votre service au service
de votre sécurité met à votre service un
service public donc pour moi les choses
sont assez claires alors noam vous en
plus j'ai vraiment besoin d'avoir et
avoir envie d'avoir votre avis pour vous
les gilet jaune sont ils victimes ou
coupables blick et gilet jaune c'est la
france
pour mme oda alors dans le débat que
vous venez de poser ils sont victimes
parce que moi je suis un technicien du
droit en tant que policier
oui je crois en la responsabilité
individuelle c'est à clichy sous bois
quand on a eu des émeutes en 2005 est ce
qu'on s'est dit bon ça brûle des
voitures à clichy donc si vous habitez
clichy vous êtes responsable des
voitures brûlées on
interpelle ça n'existe pas en droit donc
c'est des personnes qui ont commis des
délits des violences volontaires avec
arme par destination c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle le fait de rentrer dans la
foule avec des voitures et des ddt le
délit principalement constitué c'est
aussi celui de participation à un
attroupement non autorisées bon soit jeu
voilà donc nombreux c'est de l'ordre de
la responsabilité individuelle mais je
vois pas l'intérêt de ce débat de dire
est ce que tous les gilet jaune sont
coupables d'infractions est bizarre
parce que quand on dit victime ou
coupable c'est qu'aussi les gilet jaune
quand il ya des camps il ya des
débordements comme ça c'est pas
forcément des gens qui sont dans le
mouvement et des gens et voilà corse
j'ai envie de dire qu'il soit dans le
mouvement ou pas vous commettez une
infraction l'état et la une est sérieuse
mais sa part toit du bus et on appelle
les gens c'est bien le droit ça porte
préjudice aux messages que à l'image et
à l'image que pour clients mais ça c'est
peut-être la volonté certains médias de
mettre en avant
puisqu'on a eu 280 mille personnes en
rassembler samedi dernier ce sont les
chiffres du mythe à l'intérieur je sais
pas combien vous on va parler à l'heure
du travail on n'écrit pas mis le délit à
ce que je sache donc pourquoi est ce
qu'on parle pas des 275 mille cinq cents
personnes qui se sont bien comportées et
ont met la shell ont fait écran d'entre
eux trouvé que les médias font du
sensationnalisme écoutez je n'ai moi
j'ai travaillé en seine saint denis aux
renseignements généraux de
seine-saint-denis un département
particulièrement criminogènes donc les
vols de sacs à main les détériorations
de véhicules etc
c'est malheureusement le quotidien des
gens qui disent dans ce département on
n'en parle pas ou on en parle assez peu
toute l'année là quand on a un mouvement
de contestation qui politiquement peut
sembler légitime mais on peut avoir des
contestations des revendications haut
depuis une semaine c'est un bombardement
incessant de d'appel à la responsabilité
et c'est monsieur naulleau permettez moi
de vous contredire tout à l'heure mais
vous disiez des gilet jaune vous voulez
modifier la loi en appelant à la violer
mais est ce que les personnes qui sont
ici systématiquement appel à la
violation de la loi je n'en suis pas sûr
l'amérique doit d'en douter
voulant manifester dans des lieux non
autorisée en déclarant pas les
manifestations oui la préfecture il ya
une violation de la loi je voudrais
alors permettez permettait aux
techniciens du renseignement que j'ai pu
être dit ou écrit à ce sujet là c'est un
mouvement spontané et populaire il n'a
pas de représentant de qui aujourd'hui
est légitime pour déclarer est
représenté ce mouvement le jour où on
déterminera laissez moi juste deux
secondes pour terminer
mais le jour je peux vous le dire à
l'avancé le jour on déterminera des
pseudo responsables pour représenter ce
mouvement est qu on les recevra en
délégation en disant basse et batterie
enfin ce sera une escroquerie et ce sera
la fin de ces étranges comme ça qu'on
retient un mouvement sans meneur peut se
dispenser de respecter la revendication
est claire il n'y a pas besoin de
bonheur les revendications elles sont
écrites noir sur blanc les gens il ya eu
ya une goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder
un vase
certes on peut effectuer l'augmentation
du crb mais la goutte d'eau mais il ya
quand même un vase bien remplie rire
c'est un autre débat oui même débat
c'est le même débat
alors alors alors qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que ça réponde à eric noni
réussi dans la vie mais je crois qu'à
des personnes qui malheureusement ne
réussissent pas et c'est la majorité des
français aujourd'hui
saluons avec la classe moyenne ne savais
pas que l'émission porté sur moi mon
succès sur la façon de détourner le
débat tout les toutes les toutes les
lois